皆さんは
一億円という大金見たことがありますでしょうか
そこの坊や、ありますか？
ナイデスｗ
ﾌｯ
オレモナイ
マジスカｗ
まぁ貯金にはあるかもしれんがな( ⁼̴̀꒳⁼̴́ )✧
カッケェっスｗ
嘘だｗ
カッケェッスｗ(2回目)
親が管理しているからな( ⁼̴̀꒳⁼̴́ )✧
カッケェっスw(三回目)
オレの口座には今
600円しかねぇ。
リアルっスw
というわけで今回は一億円準備しました。
(けんすけ)コレが一億の重みｗ
(はじめ)コレが一億の重みｗ
(はじめ)一千万
(けんすけ)一千万
(_｀・ω・)_ﾊﾞｧﾝ×10
落ち着け
アイツら[バカ]だからきづかねぇよ。
ﾄﾝﾄﾝﾄﾝ　パッ☆
はい、という訳で
こちらが、一億円です
ちょっと剥いていきましょう。
(二人のリアクション)
ファンタスティック☆
まて
まってこれ　きつくない？
今初めて気づいたんですけど
ぱっと見あの、白紙じゃんｗｗ
何で？何で俺買ったときさぁ　ちゃんとなんか
そういう感じだったのにさぁ
まってちゃんとあけよう
HA☆Ｉ
まぁ白紙なんですけどね (　´_ゝ`）
ハイ　という訳で今回の方法なんですけれども
あなたは...仕込みです
もう第一発見者になってもいいし
あぁなるほどなるほど
あとから来て　え？みたいな
第一発見者でもう見つけよう
めっちゃ上から撮ってるから
こういうのバレない
結局さぁ触られたらバレるじゃん
触られそうになったら
けんすけが「いや、こういうの触ったらよくないんで
来るまで待っていたほうがいいでよ」とか
「マジで触んないほうがいいです」みたいな
このまま置いてあると不審になられそうなので
あたかもファンの方が置いてったみたいな感じで
それらしい封筒に入れて
「頑張ってください」みたいな、
ちょっと「少なくはありますが」「贈呈致します」みたいな
文を書いております
手紙完成しました。
金欲しい　⊃￥∀￥⊃
任せた
ｺﾞﾒﾝちょっと買出しいってきまーす
近くにカメラがあっても絶対ばれるんで
間違いなくばれにくい別の建物の、
別の建物の屋上から撮ろうと思います
セミうるせぇヽ(`Д´)ﾉ
ヤバイ×５
wwwwww
まじヤバイｗ
量ヤバッｗ
バカ言うなってｗ
え、なんもない？
えまって、触んないほうがいいよ
おおぅﾁｮｲﾁｮｲﾁｮｲﾁｮｲ
なんか、見てｗ一億円落ちてるｗｗ
まじでヤバイ
え、これ絶対偽札じゃん
え、ニセ札なの？
待って俺ね
特殊な
スキルあんのよ。
マジで触んないほうが
絶対コレどっかにカメラあるぜ？
知ってるよ？俺
無いじゃん(´・ω・`)
ww
(カメラ無さに騒ぐ一同)
っえ？これマジなやつ？
カメラあそこにあるもん
マ　マジでいっての？コレ
(ガチになる一同)
ウソでしょ？
マジでｗ
(騒ぐ一同)
まって
そういうことかｗ
グルだな？
www
(否定する一同)
俺も同じこと思ってっからw
えでも　一回さぁはじめさんにちょっと電話してから
確かに
(はじめ)ばれたｗｗ
(はじめ)ヤバイｗ
(はじめ)気づかないかなぁもうｗ
(話し合い中)
じゃカメラに撮ろう触っていいよねもう
ま一番上ぐらいにしよ
一番上...
w
えでもそれ上でしょ？
（はじめ）触っちゃたか...触っちゃたかｗｗ
ｗｗ
窃盗窃盗ｗｗ
窃盗やｗｗ
ヤバイってｗｗ×２
(はじめ)どんどん中いれっててね？
(はじめ)めっちゃ持ってくやん
(はじめ)待って×２
(はじめ)ないんだけど
いーーたーーーｗｗ
ED
俺は見たぞｗｗ
お前らが
お前らが一億円盗んだの俺は見たからなーｗｗｗ
俺は見たからなーｗｗ